ok everybody we're back and waiting
diamond at this point in the show as we
told you Ben Stiller was going to come
out the director of the new Jim Carrey
movie the Cable Guy is gonna come out
and talk about it and we're big fans of
his but he's been sick actually I
promoting the thing he's not feeling
well and I apparently he's too ill to
come and do it we're gonna get this
straight right now I want to have to
tell everybody anybody's watching
tonight that I'm very upset by this fact
that my son is not going to be on this
show tonight he's been making all the
other shows you didn't let him in he did
that Charlie Rose and he did the Foley
shows and here he comes along and he
disappoints you and I want to tell you
right now as a member of the acting
profession I find this is a disgrace I
mean I want to tell you right now I want
to apologize for my family though all is
still is everybody was ever in this
business my wife's family that my son
let us all down like this and I'm sick
of them and father's day or no fathers
they coming don't send me a car don't
give me a tie I'm finished with you
I hold no weight Terry it it's okay I
mean we like Ben he's a nice guy it's
okay it's not okay you know what this is
this is a kind of like a personal
reflection on me as an actor I mean how
do I bring my kid up what my life I'm
you know bring this kid up I give him
things I get my carlin practically I
practically teach them how to walk how
to get on the stage how to make an
entrance out of bad I mean I gave him
the Fuji camera will make his first film
all this stuff now look what happens
this is what this is the way you between
a guy like me at this point my life
what's left I mean me and George
Costanza and I got a real son I got a
real door my door Amy my son Ben these
are people I really love these are my
connection it's not its second time the
whole thing and I'm I'm getting out of
here right now but wait a minute
no it's okay good don't yell at me honey
pay no attention your father's not a
well man he doesn't feel well he has the
temperature what's the matter with you
where were you when he was born out of
town please
on the stage they're gonna walk out that
door sting
[Applause]
tonight with disaster table guys look at
the opponent party in front of the old
one you really need music okay happy
Jerry why don't you just come on the TV
show okay let's just try and get through
this yeah I'm sorry about that I'm sorry
okay
you had that stuff don't do that in
front of everybody well it's so good to
have you here thank you I'm happy to be
here yeah yeah thanks for making it and
everything and now let's talk about this
director about the movie movie okay well
I just directed the Cable Guy yeah opens
today all across the country very
excited about it very happy to be a part
of it and this is that this is a Jim
Carrey movie again star yes yes what a
good point
got told what the story's about well
it's a bit it's a bad plugin I'm over
here okay it's a it's a it's a story
about this this guy Matthew Broderick
who you know he he breaks his girlfriend
breaks up with her look at this thing
they've heard this already got Charlie
get to the good part
okay the good it's a very funny
entertaining movie uh you know it was a
lot of fun working with Jim Carrey and
we you know he's a very animated guy he
has lots of ideas you know there's a lot
of funny stuff that happened during the
making of this alright some funny stuff
okay there's a funny thing that happened
once I remember we were a funny joke you
do hear the funny thing what is you're
funny yeah I want to show it there's a
way to do these things there's a way to
tell a story and you get to the point
you go from A to B to C alright let me
tell you here's a joke okay newlyweds
they go straight from the ceremony into
the limousine that's gonna take them to
the cruise ship that's gonna take them
around the world suddenly the husband
says you know sweetheart I forgot to get
condoms it's a little too soon for us
it's not a family don't you think I mean
it's it's a honeymoon so he
I'm gonna stop off at the first
drugstore as he gets out he says oh by
the way darling do you need anything she
says yes you can get me some Dramamine
you know in case I get seasick mother
Mia
so he goes in he says to the guy I'd
like the biggest box of condoms he got
and some Dramamine the guy looks himself
do you mind if I ask you a question this
is not at all it's as if it makes you
nauseous why do you do it
[Applause]
thank you do I understand you got a clip
from the movie you know once you set up
the clip okay all right this is like I
said it's about a guy who his cable
installer basically comes over hooks up
his cable Jim Carrey hooks up Matthew
Broderick's cable and basically never
leaves him alone and starts showing up
places he isn't not invited to and
there's a pickup basketball game the
Matthew Broderick plays and then Jim
Carrey shows up uninvited and I think
that's what this clip is about let's
take this clip from the Cable Guy right
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that's good III know there's a
little friction here already and I hope
I'm not just making it worse
everything's great right I noticed one
thing that you use a your mother and
Mira does a she does the voice of the
cable of the Cable guy's mother that's
right she doesn't voiceover and III just
was gonna mention I I didn't I didn't
see Jerry anywhere in the movie actually
anywhere you didn't use yeah there's no
there's no thing I just there wasn't a
specific part that was right for my
right for a my dad move it's strange now
you're you know you do start directing
movies you don't you know you know tell
your parents what to do all of a sudden
is like this weird role reversal thing
and I I couldn't do the George Segal
yeah there's George Segal plays Matthew
Broderick's dad and and actually you
know I I couldn't do the George Segal
then you put it down George Segal and
use my voice nothing we could have done
that you weren't available you were
doing you know one of your crazy he's
doing an AT&T commercial or something
well actually I was doing his mother's
play after play which was playing in New
York and then did ask me to do can we
get serious for sure let's get serious
let's fight some more that was fun movie
and he said he got George Segal I was I
was thrilled well you know I was
thrilled that I find out we're not only
getting you today but but you as well
and we thank you yeah very nice very
nice to have you both we get
we get Jerry mom very classy the movie
the movie the Cable Guy opens tonight
everyone's gonna go see ya Colin Quinn
and the mysteries of life are coming up
we'll be right back thank you very much
guys
[Applause]